um in five four three two one welcome
back to genius pain podcast
I'm your host Bose buzzing ttan I'm
joined by special guest David self look
at tiny as a little girl you feel right
that see sorry David no no please
introduce your show her [ __ ] NPR voice
and everything no this is my sniffles
voice this podcast it will actually be
ASMR sniffles sometimes though to like I
feel like I do this honking thing when
I'm talking so I apologize in advance
let me honking like I don't think that
it happens because he goes into my nose
really yeah I'm forwarding it well I'll
tell you this everybody has been wanting
you back on this channel since you first
came on you [ __ ] mate Dave Chappelle
by the way say God was so upset yeah was
it like what's his hands feel like okay
so Lily so this is what dude I don't
think I told you this either so yeah I
met Dave Chappelle the other day and
like I just I grew up we all grew up
watching Chappelle's Show
yeah and so I knew my boss was very
close friends that I mean they're like
tight tight I knew that but it just the
ownness day it was not crossing my mind
so coming in for my lunch break and my
boss is in the lobby and he's never in
the lobby like he's always busy and he's
like oh hey I want you to meet Jonathan
and I'm like oh hey and this was a guy
that had used to work in our department
and I heard his name 1,000 times I was
excited to meet I was like oh Jonathan
Wow hey talk to him for a minute and my
boss is like hey I want you to meet
Jeremy and I'm like oh hey Jeremy good
see ya just coming back from lunch I
need to get back to my desk get to work
and I'm about to walk off and then my
boss is like Oh have you met Dave and
I'm like hey I'm in this bald beautiful
black man turns around and it is Dave
Chappelle and so like after meeting two
people that were just office people when
I heard Dave and he just called him by
the name Dave I'm thinking this is gonna
be Dave wickerwork
and he just turns around and my ass was
like visibly jarred cuz like this man
was like my childhood and then he was
like hey how you doing I'm Dave and I'm
like no no we got on your knees and you
grab his butt let me just hold you close
but thank you for everything but I mean
I teach okay and then I went upstairs I
was pacing around back and forth and
[ __ ] and then um he goes he does his
meeting and then he comes back into our
office and like I have a shared office
with somebody else you don't get the
[ __ ] out they made passionate love do
you know I did there was buzz around the
office the Dave Chappelle was in our
room because he came in and he was just
talking to us he was just shooting the
[ __ ] like he was talking about I knew
was and talking about well my cuz my
coworker and asked about that he was
talking about canceled culture he was
talking about like one of his specials
like why he quit in the smoke during it
he was just talking to us like a normal
last person and I was like am I really
at a point in my life where I'm in the
same room as Dave Chappelle and just
having a conversation or being knowledge
dude and like at one point I said some
[ __ ] and he laughed and I was like I was
like this is it this happened when she
made Dave Chappelle laugh you pretty
much good to go it's over it's over I
mean it was a light chuckle like I'm not
gonna take like a full body whole
hearted but like amen he smiled oh yeah
it was honestly like it sounds weird but
it's almost like I don't wanna be like
whack but like it's kind of like a
powerful thing cuz this is a person that
I grew up watching and now I'm just
shooting the [ __ ] with you like even if
it is for 15 minutes it kind of reminds
you like you're here now that most
excuse me mr. Dave because that's what I
would call mr. Dave Chappelle this day
excuse me mr. Dave I need you stay for
15 minutes cuz I have a friend who's
gonna run here right now not even gonna
run and I will be there a [ __ ] minute
dude guys and like I David when I talk
occasionally like occasionally like yeah
once a month maybe oh no actually now I
feel like it's been at least once every
two weeks and in the second full
phone call I'm like David and you're
like yes but David was the first [ __ ]
person I texted I don't know first
person before my mother before my
brother for my cousin's David first
because I wanted to flex on you she
knows how much I love Dave Chappelle's
like if I you know one of the biggest
reasons why I I think like I don't wanna
say I fell out of love first stand-up
but I kind of did was because like when
you do things you don't ever have to be
the top of everything right that's a
goal that I like but to say that I just
never could see myself doing stand-up as
well as like Dave Chappelle you know I
mean yeah so for me it was discouraging
not because like I I want to be not
because you have to do that with
everything that you do but for me it's
like if I can never reach a level to
something as similar to his then for me
it's like a pointless craft it's just
more like I'll do it for fun but I like
I see him and I see him work and it's
pretty amazing and I know that some
people like who aren't that big of de
Chappelle fans they can't see it because
his stand up to me is like somebody who
has crafted his who has honed his craft
so well but it just sounds like your
friend is talking to you on stage yeah
and then you don't even see a setup it's
effortless
it's [ __ ] effort Lee I'm like how do
you do that I don't sound like that one
you know what though - I think it's
because we get so caught up in like the
the YouTube world and like the digital
media of like what's your brand and like
you gotta stay true to my brand and his
brand is himself I think he a hundred
percent knows who he is I think his
brand is just Dave and he's just talking
yeah like he's really just talking his
delivery is himself is great oh you know
and I remember - cuz I just watched like
this old stand-up set of mine from like
10 years ago right and it was it was the
first time I just stand up in like a
couple years right and I hadn't done it
in so long and I wanted is when I first
came out to LA I'll say yeah let me just
do this like whatever let's listen let's
get these [ __ ] wheels greased up
again because I was doing YouTube and so
I was like let's go back in the stand at
the end and so that day I heard Bill
burr was in the house freaking worst
experience in my life because I was so
nervous now because I love Bill burr
there's two comics that I [ __ ] love
it's it's Bill burr and Dave Chappelle
so those two are my top favors and bill
burr was at the comedy
Club mm-hmm and I had I had to perform
and I remember it's recorded too I was
so [ __ ] nervous I was just blasting
through my jokes throw up oh I was I was
confident up until the point they told
me Bill Byrne was there and he's just
looking right at you like I know it was
like and it's like the most brutally
honest why why out of all days after
like two years of taking a high-end is
what bill burr have to be here and I
remember to that whole set like I
started grabbing my pants because I was
trying to prevent myself from throwing
up because I had to put grip on
something and I just kept flying through
these jokes without any real setup and I
and I was so pissed because I was like
why out of all days did you have to come
now the one time that I haven't done
stand-up is so long and you would have
to be here and it was so mortifying I
didn't do bad but when I look back at
that clip I thought I was the worst set
ever but people are cracking up I don't
know David that sucks [ __ ] front and
center I was [ __ ] like I was dying
and it sucks too because like now and
you know just to go rap back to the Dave
Chappelle thing when I watched something
like that you could tell that I'm just
trying to tell a joke rather than just
be a funny guy and that's the thing that
Dave does so well ya know mr. Dave mr.
Davis mr. Dave from now on we will only
refer to him as that's when you know
when you respect somebody when their
first name is their last name I put you
brother David all the time I'm here
brother David yeah man but Dave
Chappelle what he tells those jokes oh
that she gets my spirit and I'm like
damn dude how you doing so effortlessly
because everybody else might see them to
stand up sometimes I'm like I could tell
you're trying to do a setup like it
feels like have you ever didn't you know
when it's like oh man like I think I've
heard this trope a million times but
then when Dave talks it's like this is
just one funny [ __ ] dude yeah yeah
and I feel like and like when you're
around him like he's just like a deep
thinker like and you really feel that
Dave Chappelle told me to suck his dick
I've just all right I was slowly I was
slowly get on my knees he's like what
are you doing is I suck your dick he's
like I never asked you to
but sir mr. Dave
I'm a man of my word now David I don't
like change gears for me you know hey ty
Jack your show but as you know I don't
have my own platform so David coming
soon is my platform probably I may have
a platform soon coming soon um I want to
switch gears here David
swish Tim gears let me switch these
gears um I want to talk about something
a little sensitive but I I knew this was
the right place for this David as you
know I am from Virginia let's say I am
black I had no idea I am I'm like
nervous about even talking like about
this because I might get [ __ ] killed
oh you'd be fine I might get [ __ ]
killed no welcome to the show then
everybody tries to kill me I like
actually got nervous for a minute okay
so since I've moved out to LA sometimes
when I talk about how people are back
home people are like that's not possible
like a lot of times when people talk
about racism they're like how could how
could you be so small-minded how could
you think that's how could and I'm like
there really are people that are have a
completely different mentality than yeah
100%
and actually when I was on Tim's podcast
I talked about a like particular racist
guy that I that I kind of dated for a
while like he it was like he hated black
people and he did I mean he was never
like racist towards me but like I knew
he had a confederate flag somewhere in
his eye like I knew it he's looking for
punishment like I mean like trucks guns
leaving out in the country all that so
this this guy in particular sometimes he
posts some very concerning things on
Facebook one of the things that I
mentioned on Tim's podcast was he was
this guy that had done this post he's
like a he's obsessed with the Civil War
and he yeah it's this is getting like
it's I should have won yeah literally
but you know what he said one time he
said that he said the South would have
won if they had more reserves like that
that's yeah did this guy and so I can't
on Facebook the other day
yet made this post I guess with everyone
talking about gun control these days and
like that's kind of what I wanted to
bring up because everyone's like gun
control well we should just get rid of
these guns like we just ban them you
know and I agree with that but there was
something in my back of my mind that was
like these people are not gonna just
turn in their guns for money Oh a
hundred percent that's why the whole
take away everybody's gun in the United
States it doesn't make sense because
it's never gonna happen it people and so
everyone that's talking about control
now gun control now gun control now I
really want to remind people in opening
your eyes of the other issue of I hate
to say it but the possibility of
retaliation with how angry these people
may be for sure so this guy made this
post and this says I'm gonna skip a
little bit he said I have created a
militia page for the region of Virginia
to protect our onion alienable rights we
did not discriminate on age ethnicity or
gender all able-bodied individuals are
welcome we will be conducting firearms
training tactical training meetings
event slash rallies weekly once we have
things in order for the direction oh I'm
sorry for any of my friends that care
about your country and the direction is
going or simply your gun ownership
please join this page I've started you
don't have to come out to train with us
but it'll be greatly appreciated we will
also work together to train with other
militias in the nation in the state and
in the state to preserve our
constitutional rights if things turn
south with the current registered
legislation we will protect our gun
ownership at all costs
the and I looked in the page is very
popular it's very popular the like this
is not a [ __ ] joke like oh for sure
they're starting a militia to protect
their gut like well you know what the
thing is about that too and I think for
anybody who listens to this that's
outside of the United States I think
it's really hard for people to grasp how
much gun ownership has been ingrained
into the culture of Americans like it's
almost like if you don't own a gun you
not American mm-hmm that is how
connected people are to their firearms
over here so when people have solutions
for gun control now I'm not as
well-versed in this as Joe is right but
just from the stuff that I've read and
I've researched about here you know here
and then when Joe would talk about it
too for somebody to come up and say hey
the way for us to get rid of guns in the
United States is to take everybody's
firearms and to that I say good [ __ ]
luck good [ __ ] I think you're gonna
show up and then take it take
everybody's guns [ __ ] there are
so many illegal firearms in this for
example when I was 14 I had two Glocks
right so it's like I had two guns right
I wasn't registered one time I shot a
gun and I cry she's powerful I made
money to be on the range and I didn't
want the refund I just let I had to
Glocks didn't know how to use it right
it's just you know the older home it was
like a just in case you need somebody
[Laughter]
you know I don't want to be like a
little [ __ ] in like yeah I need this
and I would take it and then I would
take the gun in the most [ __ ] way
possible I'll have my people yeah and I
will hold it like it was a hot hot
potato chip thanks man I got this but
you know it was that easy for me to get
a gun at the age of 14 you know what I'm
saying
so you know for somebody to have a
solution to say we're gonna take all
guns in the follow suit of these other
countries who by the way are way small
in this country right not as vast just
just for example alone California and
Texas can be its own country with our
population and the infrastructure if
they want it right this podcast is
brought to you by vistaprint my friends
now have you ever received a card that's
customized a gift that's customized oh
it feels great doesn't it it shows that
they have effort it shows that they love
you shows that they didn't just get
something off a shelf wrap it up and de
stas it in your face for the holidays
when it's unique to you and when they
made it from their heart it feels great
it adds a little a little touch of
holiday love right a picture of them a
family or even their dog it feels more
personal personal it's I said personable
it's more memorable and it means more to
receive it well my friends check it out
no matter where you'll be during your
time off whether it's skiing hanging out
at beaches or settling in at home with
your loved ones nothing says Happy
Holidays like custom cards calendars and
photo gifts from Vista print and it's
awesome how you can do it man when you
go there you could pick a shape like
square or rounded corners folded or flat
and then choose one of Vista prints
designs they got everything from fun
infested to gorgeous eye catching looks
next you can put your favorite picture
right there on most of the options and
even upload a great shot right from your
phone then all you have to do is just
figure out how many you need and order
them with time to spare your
satisfaction is 100% guaranteed or
they'll make it right
either by reprinting your order or
offering a refund so this season make
more merry at vistaprint.com with up to
50% off all holiday cards and photo
calendars plus great deals on photo
gifts at vistaprint.com just enter promo
code brain 50 that's vistaprint.com
promo code brain 50 the offer expires
January 5th Demme's is fax [ __ ] it's
gonna take five Connecticut to me so if
you're trying to take away guns from
these type of people who love their guns
it's not going to happen especially
Texas oh and you know kind of the way
that I see it is everyone has a way that
they kind of everyone has a place that
they draw their power from like I as
I've never owned a gun before in order
to feel like protected and confident and
myself you know I've had to develop
power and confidence in other ways but
if somebody was like raised at 15 with a
gun and they feel protected by this gun
this is now kind of a place where they
draw their power from yeah and they
haven't had to find other methods of
this and so when you just take that away
now that person feels naked and they
feel defenseless and they will do
anything and everything to retain that
power and that's what's a little scary
because if that gun is part of
somebody's identified identity they're
not gonna just turn it in for 50 bucks
they're gonna
Sally 8:04 sure and and like and it
sucks because other countries don't have
to deal with this same mentality that we
created because of the freedom and not
only the freedom with the glorification
of guns yea because guns symbolize power
they even look scary yeah like like an
assault rifle
it looks [ __ ] scary yeah you know and
that's I I don't I don't know it's
cousin [ __ ] frightening man like even
I had a buddy who lived out in like
Tacoma Washington at the time and his
parents owned a liquor store gas station
and this fool he was like yo he goes ok
I saw you you know you're doing Muay
Thai and Jiu Jitsu and stuff right
because what do you think I should take
in order to like defend myself in case
somebody comes to the store and tries to
rob me I was like cool I want you to go
to a jujitsu store right and then right
next to it it's a gun store do you mean
teach you how to crouch and jump over
the couch catch a bullet with the
[ __ ] chokehold [ __ ] yeah bro go get a
[ __ ] gun right yeah and even for me a
guy yeah I'm scared of guns you know I
know how to use one I know you know all
the other [ __ ] just Chris Barton Joe
taught me doesn't change the fact that
I'm not scared of it it's a little
[ __ ] weapon like I'm still scared
[ __ ] but at least I know how to use it
and I know that you know but I mean yeah
it's um because we do in my opinion
obviously we have a huge [ __ ] problem
with not only guns but also something
that I'm like very adamant about is like
the media's glorification of certain
things you know when some kind of
shooting happens for a while the
person's name and their story was posted
all over the internet so these people
that felt like a nobody they could
finally become a somebody by doing
something you could be infamous it was
the fastest way to end for me and now
you feel like more people know who you
are
and that's all you ever wanted or that's
what you think you want you know you you
want to be known you want to be heard
but then you know these people that are
in the situation they're like wait this
isn't what I wanted this isn't Fame I'm
not happy and it's like well you [ __ ]
day what you did at this point yeah but
I mean there can feel like infused
teenagers confused young
lonely people that just had the wrong
perspective but what happens is this the
media blows this up and it teaches some
kid watching like you feel like a nobody
but you can be somebody go get a gun and
walk into a public place remember the
remember like nobody remembers the
[ __ ] MIT dude the way everything
Korean guy oh-o-oh in DC area it was in
Virginia I think yeah and my team
Virginia yeah Virginia yeah I don't know
[ __ ] about anything outside of
California but yeah you know him - I
think what he was like bullied or some
[ __ ] like that and then his I mean this
is not funny but it was funny because he
was taking a bunch of pictures with him
with a hammer or [ __ ] yeah because he
drew his power from that weapon yeah and
what did he do he sent them to a news
station yep and they gave him all of the
attention that he wanted I was when I
watched that [ __ ]
I started cracking up a little bit not
because the situation was terrible was
the fact that [ __ ] like you took all
these photos he's like I don't like I
don't like to lie to Gandhi so he's like
trying different like maybe if I have a
hair bow a little high I'm like all
serious and Emilee gun control and Dave
is like he needed the light picking him
off the side putting like some
foundation on his face oh my kpop style
you know I gotta make a sure if I'm
gonna go out it's gonna be a good one
but you know that that's the funny thing
they like I think if a lot anybody who
hasn't been a bully before or pushed
into a corner they don't know why
somebody would do something like that I
know a lot of people this should have
gotten bullied is why no it kind of
changes your perspective a lot like this
kid I don't know what the hell he went
through but he was an Asian immigrant
well I'm not sure he was in me but he's
Asian kid in Virginia right and you know
yeah I'm saying yeah a little some races
white people probably made a few jokes
in a few a few hot thousands I literally
cannot like out of
school I went to I think I remember one
Asian guy so I'm saying ya know so he
was like that oddball out and it was
probably hard for him to deal with that
[ __ ] yeah and the funny thing is like
you feel like when you push somebody to
a corner they're not gonna do something
if you see animals and you push them to
a corner no matter how weak you you
think that they are yeah they show their
teeth absolutely absolutely absolutely
like at first you like you could run up
on a rabbit and at first it'll like keep
running away but like I don't know
I [ __ ] my bite you I think you
look yeah they do I do it this is gonna
go into that [ __ ] weird reddit page
the JK girls just do it real slow then
look into the camera and go I saw that
uh that [ __ ] reddit page once and
that [ __ ] is one of the funniest things
about it is what it's all TIFF it's it's
literally 90% oh really oh my god it is
like dude and I was telling her about
this [ __ ] too because I'm like I'm
didn't hear thinking I'm like geo
smoking hot
Nikki smoking hot Julia smoking hot
[ __ ] yes pretty hot too but yeah the
whole thing is Tiff's big ol milkers
like there's you know there's in the
thing is is it like I don't see it
because I was like scrolling through the
[ __ ] because I just found this like two
weeks ago and I was looking through it
and I was like oh that's picture TIFF oh
this picture TIFF but then I would
notice bro it's like the table is flat
but then these titties like up over the
table like what's she doing she's like
dude I'm trying to be on this reddit
page she's just dressed her titties on
the table and it told me a minute to
notice that it was the breasteses it's
also because maybe it's because she also
posts the most out of everybody I think
I was good she's a bad [ __ ] like it's
what I can't see her like that because
that met her was you super young Tim's a
bad [ __ ] though she got a good face big
old titties she young she fine she out
here TIFF is 30 now which blows my mind
man really oh [ __ ] that bit just 30
years old now man yeah dude I I googled
how old you were before I came here
yeah man 32 yeah Wow
goodnight crazy crazy David I'm still
I'm still returning baby yeah I am 32
yeah yeah it's about that age [ __ ] I
miss me all the time how do my [ __ ]
back went out yesterday [ __ ] goddamn it
I'm getting old now man I like this age
though I think when I think when I was
younger I used to think thirty was super
old mmm-hmm but then if I if somebody
asked me right now like a Kent you
wouldn't you don't you wish you could go
back in time and be young and be like
nah because it took me a while to be
comfortable in my own skin and that that
happened through time yeah I can't go
through that anxiety again oh I can't I
can't do that [ __ ] I can't go through
second-guessing every single step that I
make I'm at a point in my life where I'm
I still second-guess a lot but it's
nowhere near how it used to be because
I'm more solid right now my foundation
is strong it's like what I say [ __ ] you
now I mean it it's crazy
it comes from my spirit because you know
you're like I don't need you I have a
plan here's my five-year plan and I
don't see you in this go [ __ ] yourself
yeah it feels [ __ ] good like I could
say my opinions without worrying too
much about the repercussions because I
just don't give up [ __ ] yeah because
before it was like this is like
something small so you know let's say
you had a group of friends right in this
some [ __ ] that always happens in high
school and you know if you're in high
school and you live this you know this
you know what's up you have a group of
like let's say 10 friends right but you
know 10 friends in high school yeah yeah
yeah that's right - the zero yeah but
you're like 10 friends right and there's
probably let's say eight of them you
really like but two of them you really
don't [ __ ] with okay right but with
those two that you don't [ __ ] with
because you're so worried about the
perception of the group and then you
know keeping things cool you just you
keep you see you're always nice to them
and you always invite them out well
guess what kids when you move past 18
and you're like in your 30s those two
people are never invited to cookout
ever because you don't have to be around
people you don't want to be around in
high school because you have to go to
this thing called school you have to be
around them 24/7 so you have to look at
their face hear their voice when you're
an adult and you couldn't create your
own situations you can choose who you
want to be around that is what I love
about being an adult it's like look at
look at this I don't like you
don't come near me I will [ __ ] in your
food I will literally [ __ ] in your food
I will wait for you to have a child just
so I could kidnap your kid yeah you lost
me at 10 friends can't relate yeah I
mean with my with my high school friends
till this day really we've we've had we
had this league called friends gaming of
course and we've had it since we were 14
god damn I never I just started always
been pretty quiet for me this whole time
this is the first year that like I've
non-stop had people hang out with and oh
my god David I'm going home for the
first time this year in three years and
like yes dude and my schedule is like
jam-packed like there's because okay I'm
I am like undoubtedly like at least firm
maybe like my three years of high school
like those that span of grades I'm
definitely the like I don't like
probably I don't wanna say most more
successful but more kind of popular like
outward facing thing because like I have
the following like I do you know [ __ ]
like this I'm out in LA like a lot of
people are still back at home and so
it's really funny that all of these
people that really [ __ ] on me growing up
like really [ __ ] on me like now
there's kind of like I don't wanna see
like a buzz about me like back home
because it's a really really small town
but like suddenly people that didn't
want anything to do with me I'm so proud
of you [ __ ] years ago they're like
I'm so proud of you I always knew you're
gonna make it yo man you're doing great
things do you get that all the time oh
my god eight it may never they never
wanted to do guys work your ass off work
your ass off the Flex it feels good tell
them to suck your [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
know what okay what suck your [ __ ] I
like that phrase because as I suck my
dick
but the reason is so funny because when
people do do that like I've there are
people who have literally reached out to
me they go yo man high school was a trip
right and I look at that and I'm like
who the [ __ ] are you like I don't even
know you
this podcast is brought to you by a rake
on my friends are you walking around
listening to your lovely podcast such as
genius brain with wired earbuds what are
you do
when you idiot that is uncomfortable if
you're going on long walks you don't
want this wire dangling around your face
like a loose hair you want wireless
earbuds and you want premium quality
that won't break your bank but sounds
amazing and looks really dope well
that's why you have a break on my
friends break on just release their best
model yet the e25 SS e 25s they have six
hours of playtime seamless bluetooth
pairing more bass any more compact
design that gives you a nice noise
isolating fit break ons wireless earbuds
are so comfortable perfect for on-the-go
listening and for talking on the phone
you could talk on the phone dude if you
haven't talked on the phone with
wireless earbuds that stuff is matrix
tough it's number one I hate putting a
phone to my face and if I could just
walk around and relax while just talking
through my earbud pieces without a wire
per thick then Drakon has your back
unlike some of other wireless options
rate content buds are both a stylish and
discreet with no dangling wires or stems
you've heard me talk about how the
company was co-founded by Ray J and
celebrities like Snoop Dogg uh-huh and
other steps are obsessed with ray cons
so pick up a pair let's see what the
hype it's all about now's the time to
get the latest and greatest from Ray
Khan get 15% off your order at buy rake
on Comm slash brain that's buy rake
on.com slash brain for a 15% off rake on
wireless earbuds buy rake on comm slash
brain dude I know there was a guy that
sat behind me in social studies for like
because our last names were similar for
like years we never really spoke one day
he followed me on Instagram and I was
like oh I'll follow him back and then he
just starts responding to every story
and I'm like we literally never spoke
high school is a trip right what the
[ __ ] are you talking about mean your
life this was a while ago but somebody
no Sacramento is not that big of a town
and if you if you if you say some [ __ ]
people probably here that's why I want
to tell stories from back in Sacramento
I don't use the actual names right
because it's a small town you know word
gets around like that but this guy was
going around I don't even know this dude
like I kind of remember his face for
maybe like a yearbook or maybe I seen
him on school or something around school
[ __ ] but he was saying some [ __ ] like oh
like David's like [ __ ] persona that
he puts online that's some new [ __ ] he
never like that in high school and I'm
like thinking like you don't even know
me how would you know this how would you
[ __ ] know this you've never had a
conversation with me you never gave me
the time of day yeah you know what I
mean like it's like you never ever
[ __ ] talk to me I've been the same
dude since [ __ ] day one you know all
my friends know this [ __ ] you know I've
probably gotten a lot louder since I
gotten older because I gave less [ __ ]
but other than that it's been the same
[ __ ] guy I mean you could ask any of
my friends from back at home but this
random person who doesn't know me he
wants to gain a little bit of attention
and fame by talking [ __ ] about me to
other people around my thing and the
funny thing is I'm not a
non-confrontational person so you know
and I had to do this a couple of times
with people and not to say like I wasn't
a fighter throw down I'm not gonna I'm
not confrontational there's a fist
fighting but if you have a problem we
should be able to talk about it so I was
at a site called Vaughn's it's called
Safeway you know back in a North caocao
I was at a Safeway saw this dude kind of
looks he's kind of like you know doing
that shifty eye thing like uh like
whether he should approach me or not oh
you know you're one of those things
right probably like he wonders like does
he know does he know I've been talking
[ __ ] yeah and so like I just got like
what's up bro he's like it what's up man
how you doing dude it's like you've been
doing big things already my blood
pressure is starting to rise and I was
like that's cool man I was like hey bro
like I don't even know you like that but
how come you'd like tell all these other
people that like I'm not who I am he's
like nah now you getting [ __ ] twisted
man that's not what I said I'm like what
is going on with this dude right this is
like this [ __ ] made nice and people
like if you're gonna talk that [ __ ] at
least own up to it my thing is like if I
talk [ __ ] behind your back I was believe
every sin to your face yes that's
exactly what I'm saying
like it's not even like oh if I talk
[ __ ] about you you can approach me and
we'll like hash it out like no I've
already said it to you yeah in fact I
make sure that I say it to you before
I'd go say it to anybody else and if you
know if I'm saying it [ __ ] you like
seriously I and I have no problem if if
I get to a point where I'm talking about
somebody to somebody else it means I've
exhausted all resources solving the
problem with the person yeah and I'm
done with it I'm dead I'm venting I'm
fed up like I don't talk [ __ ] to talk
[ __ ] if I'm talking [ __ ] it's probably
to vent but it's because
you [ __ ] pissed me off we've been
trying to work this out it's not working
out I've told you to go [ __ ] yourself
and here we are how is that talking [ __ ]
behind your back
I've already said it to the front of
your face exactly what is it we're just
not adding anything negative yeah we
just can't say anything negative like no
like I don't like you yeah that's okay
that's okay like if if you don't if we
don't I feel like I'm talking like you
know what if I don't like you and I'm
talking [ __ ] about you talk [ __ ] back to
me that's just unless just hash out
we're like great we don't like each
other at least robbing fun I get to yell
at you you get to give me constructive
feedback it's funny too cuz there's some
other people like I talking mad [ __ ]
about certain people that I really don't
like and it is it's very rare that I
actually dislike somebody right so like
if I do dislike them like this like them
a lot but the funny thing is is like I
hear things that they've said about me
which doesn't really affect me I'm just
more like damn like you know like like
that that's cool right it's like I never
liked you too but you're going out of
your way to talk that [ __ ] but the funny
thing is they forget you talk [ __ ] I
could talk to you wait better than you
so let's listen let's get let's do this
[ __ ] right so if she gets a little out
of hand and then Austin I receive a
message through somebody else because
they can't confront me
they tell one of our mutual friends you
know just tell David it's all love man
that's all good oh now I'm just gonna do
it more times more you you you [ __ ] up
like don't give me don't give me ammo
don't give me ammo to know that it
affects you like that on the daily yes
I'm doing it for sport and fun but if
it's hurting your feelings now I like it
even more I I mean I have to say though
- I'm in this I'm in this point in my
life where I think in my early 20s I
would I was like very emotional and very
reactive yeah and very people pleaser II
just like a lot of unfavorable qualities
and I was always stressed out always
always trust out and like now I'm in
this spot where everything I want my
life to be as stress-free as possible
like if I don't like you I'm probably
just gonna I'll probably either stop
talking to you or I've actually I think
like just last year or like the
beginning the year I had a girl that we
were really close for six months she was
a really bad compulsive liar and it was
stressful for me
because I don't want to have to I don't
have to feed like when we speak I know
what you're saying is true there's no
extra thought in it I had to put
everything that she said through a
filter of is she telling me the truth
and I mean that coupled with a few other
things I was just over it and so like I
kind of stopped talking to her and she
kept probing and eventually I was like
hey we've talked about this it's an
issue I don't this feels kind of like a
toxic friendship I'm like I care about
you but you know and I kind of I
literally broke up with a friend and I
try to do things in the least
stress-free way possible because I don't
want to deal with it later
I don't want that I damn I'm more like
let's talk to [ __ ] out what's up let me
try like I don't I don't have that thing
of like hey he's like even with breakups
right even if I did have a great big
breakup let's say it like we split I'm
just like what ever happens to you I
could give a [ __ ] like be with God god
oh my god that's gonna be my twenties
Wednesday like if you are not additive
to my life go be with God like I don't
know if it's because and I'm finding
that a lot of people aren't on this
wavelength that I have where it's just
more not like my wavelength is better
but it's not about if I don't like you
if you [ __ ] died I don't care it's
like I literally could get and that's
like the most UNCHR iced like being
about me we don't maybe I'm trying to
fix a little bit because I'm trying to
be more Jesus like yeah yeah I know
but if you were the Anointed One I am
but like like I said I if I [ __ ] with
you I [ __ ] with you uh if you have
wronged me deeply if you died I would
shed a tear of joy I was I would find
where you live wait for you to die and
then right before you pass the way I
would look into your eyes I would reach
out my hand and clasp your head and say
you know what I would I would go away
then I will show up at the funeral they
would be buried I would get a man to
make hardwood floors above his grave put
tap shoes and then start river dancing
all over the things well yelling you got
what you deserved and then I would
chisel on his with God go with God
I'm a petty man man I feel like like
pettiness is the thing that keeps me
going but I mean like if that's your
that yeah I don't know I can't relate
David penny Wahby oh that's what they
call me Eddie Wow I'll be petty well oh
my gosh that's who the [ __ ] I am I have
to I have to like okay I've also I also
went on this new C I feel like we're
very different in this sense because
like David I got to live that
stress-free life like I want it like I
know for sure it's like I think your
route is very very healthy it's super
good your route is pleasurable it's very
pleasurable and the thing is like I
don't stress about it either yeah I mean
like when when like somebody I just like
comes up to me or if we have a
confrontation
it happens in that moment and then I
move on it's just like in the moment I'm
in the moment and then life goes on I
think that's how my parents all things
though like I've always seen my parents
get into like these huge fights and
shit's all bad and then after its salt
they're just like and then life's good
I I'm like that too but you know I I
kind of like how to like dive in and I
was talking to somebody about this other
day I think I was talking about it on
the girls podcast we're basically like
look I'm at a point where I've been
through so much [ __ ] like really bad
[ __ ] you know and I'm a very sensitive
person so any of my bad situations yeah
I think it they get magnified like times
four but I think that's great because I
haven't had to go through any like
insane traumas or issues I just had to
deal with some unfavorable things but I
felt them a lot more deeply I feel like
then some people do and because of that
when little arguments arise or something
I don't have time for it I absolutely do
not have time for you like and I think
that's why they say like [ __ ] like that
comes with age because when you're
younger you haven't you haven't dealt
with a lot of bumps in the road so every
bump in the road feels so traumatic but
as we get older we've like I last
here I literally lost my job without
notice while I'm out in California a
single woman with no savings I was like
that's [ __ ] scary and then compared
to if somebody wants to talk [ __ ] to me
on Twitter I do not give a [ __ ] like
I've been through worse stuff and I
think that's like for all of us it's
interesting because I know like when you
know in social media happens I don't
think a lot of people are ready for the
type of what's the word I'm looking for
toxic environment social media is right
yeah because we we want to take all the
good from something but we don't want to
recognize the bad right and so when you
put yourself out there and like
specifically social media right you're
putting yourself out there to be judged
constantly and that's just the space
that you're in you have to have the the
right mental fortitude to understand
that this is what this space is meant
for it is like if you come out here and
you you for example if you're young then
you go I want to be YouTube famous and
you just you [ __ ] drink in all these
great comments then there's one comment
that says your [ __ ] [ __ ] is done and
then you dwell on this one negative
comment and it eats you up on the inside
it's because you didn't prepare yourself
mentally for what the real world wait
like yes
what's out there you know what's funny I
so similarly to that I I was watching
there's there's been this uprising of
commentary channels that are not well it
was commentary now they're just
criticism channels yeah anytime
something happens there's like a slew of
youtubers they have to talk about it and
it's usually pretty intense and one of
the big topics it's come up has been
have you seen Lily Singh's show or late
night show yeah I have not and is it bad
you gotta watch the videos man people
are tearing it apart and people made a
really great point
Lily's thing was this youtuber that came
up ten years ago she amassed 15 million
followers all of her fans and they told
her Lily you're great Lily you're
amazing Lily Lily Lily Lily Lily but the
room will come
and then she goes into traditional media
and they're like you can't host you
can't tell jokes you can't write you
can't do this and your audience is all
kids but we gave you something that's
more adult facing like a talk show but
your entire audience is like under 15
and they don't want to watch this yeah
and and it just it didn't mesh and it's
like I don't know if she was ready to go
into traditional media because she was
drinking her own [ __ ] kool-aid oh
that's what it was I feel like there's a
lot of youtubers that do that it's not
just her - by the way if you guys are
[ __ ] on that that's all of you dude
that's me included we get caught up in
our own [ __ ] [ __ ] all the time
right and we gas ourselves up we think
weirdo that's why I always like to tell
myself David so you are not [ __ ] and the
reason why is because I need to be on my
[ __ ] toes yeah I hear that I need to
be on my toes like it's not a bad thing
for me to say I will never be a Dave
Chappelle staff member you know yeah
this is me recognizing certain things
and the number one is how much time am I
going to dedicate to this and do I
really have the the innate ability to do
this yes I need to figure this stuff out
yeah and it's okay if you don't have it
you'll be great at other things
amazing how many youtubers don't take
formal training oh there are a few think
of the [ __ ] they and they're like well
I've already got all these views I've
got all this I'm great and it's like but
you need to be prepared for these other
things what about when you don't do
YouTube forever they're not thinking
about that I think but you know what I
think also like to an extent we have to
drink our own kool-aid because every I
don't know if y'all know this every like
I was gonna say every I will say like
80% of youtubers are [ __ ] sad I mean
like yeah depressed very they're always
looking back at their peak and saying oh
I'm gonna get back to that you know
whatever it was that made me faint but
that thing that means you're famous five
years ago it's not a trend anymore so
you have to do something above all yeah
you have to
and they're looking back at their past
they're looking at their numbers like to
an extent our lives every day and I
think you and I like we've kind of gone
paths where we're not looking at it as
much but for some people every day their
life is defined by a number whether it
be their likes their YouTube views their
Twitter likes their brand deal numbers
their comet everything their entire
persona is rated on a scale of one to a
thousand or you know something it like
that that [ __ ] is so unhealthy but so
many of us go into this because we're
insecure because we're damaged and then
we have to drink our kool-aid a little
bit but you got to take it with a grain
of salt you can't tie your entire ego to
these people that don't really know you
telling you that the best person ever
and you can do anything here's the thing
like you know with somebody like Lilly
Singh I saw a couple of videos back in
the day and you know what I say a couple
of videos I mean it's literally like two
or three videos like that's really about
it not because I'm hating on a
[ __ ] blow that [ __ ] that because
I like a woman that just blows her nose
tight but not because like what the [ __ ]
was I saying
oh but Lilly see not because like I'm
I'm a hater or something cuz I if I like
something I'll continue to watch it but
I give it a couple of tries right right
and so with Lilly I could understand
definitely why herself when I found out
that she had a late night show I I could
have thought of a lot of different
people who had done a way better job and
not because I'm hating on her it's like
you said like her average demographic
has to be from the age to to like 14 so
what the [ __ ] was a late night show
gonna do for her I mean for her to think
that she was gonna kill it on that stage
also shows a little no self-awareness I
mean it and it's a big job it's like
it's a big I think you're like on set
what daily for 10 hours you're
essentially the showrunner I mean that's
it
god that's such a big jump and then also
like maybe back up like I'm a big
proponent of taking classes you know
work I'm sure she's taking a million and
a half classes but like but you know I
also feel for her too because she came
into YouTube in the golden era and
everyone hyped her up and you know what
else is kind of [ __ ] up I genuinely
believe the network predominantly picked
her because I've been in this situation
before because she is a minority female
and she's pretty yeah she's beautiful
yeah like they it's almost like
sometimes people use us
particularly minority females because
they're like great this slots in
perfectly this makes it look good yeah
like number one
aside from hurt sitting in her own room
talking to herself what was her crowd
work that she's ever done before aside
from doing these concerts of little
children that come to see her go up on
stage and do these terrible raps like
one when is what was her pedigree you
know any mean does she was she a
stand-up comic does she do improv shows
like what what is it right I was saying
is every Tonight Show gonna be her doing
an Indian accent of her parents like who
what what did you think was gonna happen
and when I saw that stuff and I think I
said on a JK news I'm like I didn't know
it was doing that terrible right but I
feel I said like I'm not sure if I was
mentioning her but there were certain
youtubers like for example like grace
Helbig yeah like she was when she did
her show her show bombed and it was two
years ago she went linear to like what
network was it on I can't remember buddy
was a talk shows on billboards
everywhere in Hollywood oh really is she
bombed and I felt like sometimes people
are setting up these people to fail a
little bit but it was because and that's
what's [ __ ] up I think probably with
grace Helbig if it was a big Network
like she's really big and they're like
oh she's gonna give us numbers and then
you have to set it up right there
exactly and then for Lilly Singh they
were like okay she's a youtuber
she's a minority and she's female
perfect and they kind of set her up to
fail
yeah with because anybody should have
seen like hey we need to tighten this up
you know another thing with Colleen
behringer Miranda sings
they gave her a Netflix show because
Netflix wanted to use her for her
viewership and her demographic they were
like this woman is going to pull in this
new audience and then when they didn't
do the work to bridge the traditional
and the YouTube because that's Netflix
his job they have to when they didn't do
the work to bridge those two then they
said all those youtubers have a shelf
life all those youtubers can't make it
in traditional you had a curate like you
carried all your other talents exactly
why and in here you have this person
that you can really leverage like Lilly
leveraged her clean leverage her but
they expect them to do all of the work
and they expect the followers to just
come and where are the marketing dollars
behind me shows - yeah exactly where are
they you know like I don't I don't
and I think it's also the networks
failing the creators and then they want
to say then the traditional media wants
to say like oh you tubers can't make it
it doesn't work and if we're talking
about this because I know I read that
comment multiple times let's talk about
Lilly Singh's talk show which it's so
funny I didn't I didn't even look into
it cuz I didn't but you had a comment on
this cuz I'm always asking like what's
what's in this podcast you want me oh
[ __ ] I brought it up and they talked
about the lily scene but I didn't know
that it was a hot topic recently I
thought it was like oh wait she's had a
talk show for a while now so I'm like oh
is there something new with it I didn't
really look into it but I didn't know it
was like getting roasted like that well
it's you know what I'm gonna be honest
like it like I feel like we're like
we're not even like roasting it right
now and we're kind of like singeing on
it but these these criticism channels
are really roasting it but they are also
using her for their viewership to you
know like when we brought this up we're
just using it as a conversation piece
because we know about both sides the
industry I work so heavily with
traditional media and you know you're
literally doing you you know you're
doing a lot of [ __ ] i I really think
that there is a disconnect with these
company should have had or like on I
think a great linear thing was her being
on like Sesame Street first like not as
a joke like if she has a younger
audience because they always bring in
celebrities for second street right how
dope would have been for her to be again
they have the connections to do that or
if in bc NB c-- has a great PR team if
NBC reaches out to a youtuber with a
similar crossover audience have her do
collabs have her do 20 collabs before
the show launches drum up some hype that
is their responsibility and they're not
doing their due diligence and then they
just blame it on the creators yeah cuz I
saw the the few videos that I saw were
this uh it was when she was doing the
she was she imitates her parents a lot
saying anything which I thought was like
funny for the first like you know first
time and then I saw a second fear she
did the same thing I was like oh she's
just gonna do this until it gets beat to
the ground and then I saw her on The
Daily Show with Trevor Noah and that's
when I was like this girl doesn't it's
not very good outside of her own camera
because she was trying to do these jokes
like on The Daily Show right over
everybody's head because it was terrible
or just was so bad and I was like oh and
then when I found out on JK news that
she was gonna get her own talk show I
was like did they not see her on The
Daily Show she's not read
for this but they also that's not her
audience there instead of also she's
just she's really bad at jokes like it's
terrible it was it was like the jokes
were [ __ ] terrible it was like it's
like she almost laughing to make sure
just to try to get the crowd laugh with
her but so bad yeah but she also like I
think her I haven't really like caught
up on the whole show I just saw clips
from it but I think that they have her
do kind of a stand-up thing in the
beginning and so but that's also the
thing dude she does skits she does skits
you guys have the dollars for it do
skits like like skip the segment like
dude just do a skit to open every other
week it [ __ ] bat shoot them they know
that they can do that and like oh I
don't get it in my opinion I think it's
the network's failing them and the
network's wanting to use these creators
for their demographic and the audience
they bring in but they're not helping
they just want to have them do all the
work and when it doesn't work out they
blame it also could be on her and two of
her once again not being self-aware and
she probably sold herself as a person
that could do everything it's like I got
this this is cake this is easy so they
maybe they probably [ __ ] bought some
of her [ __ ] too cuz I know with some
of these meetings like these guys they
talk about themselves so big you know
yeah they're not grounded they don't see
that [ __ ] like oh this might be hard
like III did a recent show on Netflix
and prior to I know that what I'm doing
on this show is something that I've done
constantly right but it doesn't mean
that I wasn't [ __ ] nervous like i sat
there and i was like okay i got to make
sure that i killed this i need to make
sure that i know what's going on so i
did my due diligence i sat down i saw
the other productions of shows that
they've done is similar to this so i got
the vibe and the feel of it i got to
know who the co-hosts was and i'm
sitting there doing my research I'm not
going in there thinking that I'm gonna
kill it and knock it out the park I'm
praying that that'll happen but I have
to make sure that I'm on top of my game
right but a lot of the times with some
of these youtubers they're given so
[ __ ] much they're not grounded they
don't know what it's really like that's
fair and how it's supposed to be so on
her and to maybe you know I'm just
playing the other side like maybe for
her she was like oh this is gonna be
cake like I got this [ __ ] I'm funny
people laugh I get millions of likes all
the time
that's cool you're on a different
platform now so what are you gonna do
and that's the thing like you have to be
well-versed in this thing I couldn't
think that my YouTube acting was good
enough when I went to go do my own film
I did it I got linked up with my friend
Justin who showed me the ropes he worked
on my [ __ ] acting and I made sure
that I had to knock it out the [ __ ]
Park on the Sundance flex and then we
had and then but people don't understand
the work it took it to get there you
know what I mean I knew how bad I was
like that acting I was good at five
minutes sketches now how do I take that
and do a [ __ ] hour-and-a-half film
yeah like yourself yeah but I mean like
I'm also I agree and disagree with that
David I'm agreeing to disagree because
I'm a big I'm a big fake it till you
make it person like for example the job
that I have right now i am i feel like i
am so under qualified you are qualified
though i but that's the thing i grew
into it i grew into it and I did grow
into it very quickly because I was so
scared
but like when opportunity presented
itself I jumped on it and I had to Huff
myself up and say yeah I could do this
but when I got into the position of it
like some of me with the lily thing I
was like okay what classes do I need to
take what courses do I need to take what
do I need to do like okay I got it now
let me make sure I live up to those
expectations and so I I see what you're
saying but that everybody's you them you
entertain like and I also two people
don't know you're actually a very
thorough and diligent person you have
[ __ ] but you already have [ __ ] booked
out I don't even booked [ __ ] yeah I just
see what happens my life is really
sawdust and I throw it in the [ __ ]
wind and then I see what happened
it has anything grown yeah you know what
I say would be with God that's all so I
say to myself
yo you [ __ ] [ __ ] be with God cuz I
throw my [ __ ] out you on the other hand
are a very methodical person you you you
you're not a very haphazard human being
I'm not sure if you know this about
yourself you're not very half Hazzard
you have goals you set things up and you
make sure things happen I don't really
have that I have to know exactly but
that's you there's not a lot of people
who do that there's not everybody in
this world who actually has set plans
set goals and they find the exact way to
tackle an if
doesn't they shift and they move in
another room that's you you are not
afraid you are not is this free bird
your life is a grid and you [ __ ] plug
[ __ ] him Oh
find me also what a great cop I'm saying
I'm trying to take a little piece of
what you do but for some reason I can't
do it like even with the podcast right
the funny thing is like these commenters
they got my ass they're like well why
don't you tell us you're gonna do this
I'm like [ __ ] I didn't think about it
though you know I mean they're like why
don't you at least tell us you and do a
podcast instead if you're switching it
up I'm like mmm I've been really smart
but I didn't really do that yeah and so
like I think like you're I think that
comparison to yourself which I hope most
people can be like that but it's very
hard for people to do what you do it's
it's not easy because a lot of us are
just so scatterbrained a lot of people
are even some people who say that
they're organized I look at that I'm
like you're as organized as I am dude
which means you are not organized I feel
like I'm not really organized though I'm
just more so like goal oriented and like
overly determined that's very like
overly determined man I I mean I got a
little roasted too because I own the
Jake in whose eyes you know what Lily
sing she wrote a book about it's like
how to be a unicorn or something right
it was like this book it's like a life
experience book right and I'm like how
to be a boss that's how to be a poser
boss yeah yeah look at in my mind I'm
like what have you done yeah like just
from an adult from another perspective
it's like what have you lived in but you
know what that book is for right for
little kids
no it's for it that means that she's
look David you know other side of the
industry she got an agent her agent said
okay we hire a ghostwriter for $10,000
you tell them about your life and now we
sell the book you know we make 150,000
or $500,000 and me as the agent I take
my $100,000 cut and you're gonna do this
because of that that's why all of this
random [ __ ] comes out if you have a
youtuber that you really like and
suddenly they have a self health book or
a new hockey club or like a new they
just got an agent that's what it is the
agent just signed on in the agent wants
20 percent or 10 percent whatever it may
be that's where all this [ __ ] comes from
100% but for her case I don't think
that's what it was I think for her she
was like sucking at all [ __ ] clenched
up trying to I don't want to say suck my
dick because that that's that's - I'll
try to be progressive you know I'm
saying ya know Devi this 2019 you suck
in her own dick said [ __ ] you know what
I'm [ __ ] her ii don't clip that
sounds better and I feel like she does
feel like she has something she does to
a younger audience like I'm like I said
I don't hate on the chick though but you
know this is just like me thinking about
like what it is to be in our head right
now you know going through something
like this and it's maybe a little
learning lesson for us like you know
that'll just be like somebody like me
who just doesn't give a [ __ ] just reach
reach constantly reach it and people
tell you you're out of line be like [ __ ]
you [ __ ] keep walking just keep walking
and doing your own thing but once again
I'm also somebody who doesn't have her
views I don't have her viewership I
don't have her reach either so she's
like she's way beyond me you know I
don't know I I think we I think we
agreed to disagree a little bit of that
topic yeah for sure
I agree with you though on Fox with that
though I don't actually disagree with
you god I feel like that's how it is for
most people I just don't think it's her
her case god I love and I have
conversations people when we don't agree
about the same thing but like we're
still like actively listening today is
that that's so wack I'm at the age where
I'm like wow I love active listening and
dynamic conversation sometimes I get
sucked up into the whole Twitter thing
because I expect people to do that to
disagree without using attacking words
yeah and they sometimes people say dumb
[ __ ] and then if I say like yo this is
why it's incorrect and they come out and
like I talked about this on a video
recently where people don't know how to
prove their point without bringing in
like superfluous [ __ ] so for example
this is what a lot of people do online
you and I have a disagreement right
it'll be let's say about the color blue
right or let's say it's I don't know is
why the color let's say that's the topic
right I'll be like white is not a color
right and you'll be like yes white is a
color I was like no white white isn't
the color because of this this and this
right and then you would say well these
probably you don't like white people
because you're an Asian man and white
people are did some other [ __ ] to you so
it's a racial thing it's like
where did that come from you know I mean
so a lot of times when people argue they
get caught up in their feelings and they
bring up all these random stuff that are
hot topics or like social justice issues
and they make it into this bigger
Universal issue right to bolster their
argument to get an emotional support and
I [ __ ] hate that because nobody ever
addresses what's being said like I had a
I about my opinion about like crazy
kpop fandom right yeah which I think I'm
okay to say an opinion about that I'm a
Korean man listened to Korean music I
covered Korean music I've been asked to
do like these Korean idols like singing
shows which I said no like I've I know a
lot of people in the Korean music
industry and I state my opinion about
Korean k-pop fandom and their argument
is well you don't know about this [ __ ]
because blah blah blah blah everybody
thinks that we're all this this and that
that and I'm like okay we're talking
about two different things
you know I mean I'm talking about my
opinion about what k-pop fandom is and
then you're talking about you being made
fun of because you like kpop so you know
and the funny thing about my biggest
issue with like hardcore k-pop fans they
actually think that they're an oppressed
group the way they talk about when
they're being made fun of or like well
they are they are oppressed but for
other reasons and but the thing is is
that for them kpop is their identity
it's their escape and when you when you
attack kpop when you attack kpop you
think you're attacking a thing but they
see you as attacking their sense of self
which is stupid but I mean that's that's
what it is
but that's the problem though right it's
like they go as a group it's like you
are not a religion you are not a race
you are not an oppressed group but is
there's no more is it their coping
mechanism David get the [ __ ] out of your
face is what I'm saying right because it
sits with this one specific music genre
right you know what I mean and it's like
you have to learn how to separate that
thing eventually I'm talking about it
cause if you're a young teenager I
understand you after your [ __ ] yeah
they're a [ __ ] adult and you haven't
separated those two that people can
dislike what you like and not saying I
don't like you as a person you grow the
[ __ ] up yeah I do agree with that that's
what it is 14 15 year olds because
that's what I think a lot of like the
kpop fandom are
like that's fine you get a passenger
young it's your coping mechanism but for
adults I say more so it's not healthy
you you you can't put your ident and a
lotta - there's a lot of people early
20s late 20s that their identity is not
them their identity as a thing and it's
completely tied to that thing
sometimes somebody's identity is their
entire sexuality and so when you know
the LGBTQ community gets attacked they
are under attack fully or the I mean
there's a lot of people that do that
they tie their interests into their ego
and it's not healthy for them and that's
what I'm trying to say that is exactly
you word it so much better that's what I
mean by you weren't like you are you are
not your interests exactly you are you
yeah I mean and it's so [ __ ]
unhealthy to identify yourself as
something as fleeting as a genre of
music yeah right because everything
becomes a personal attack now it goes
you don't like this person well [ __ ] you
let me tell you something about this
Asian men are attractive where are you
going with this nobody's talking about
that and even if they didn't find Asian
men attractive people are allowed to
have their [ __ ] opinions that's
that's a lot that's something that
people don't really vibe with I think a
lot people say that you're allowed to
have your opinion but you only say that
if it only coincides with yours yeah
that's that's problematic for me yeah
because I can have an opinion with you I
think your opinion is stupid or not but
I could still [ __ ] with you as a human
being and that's okay yeah and I just
people would I wish people would
understand that a little more well it
also like it also comes in the fact that
people that tend to absorb a thing as
their identity it comes from not liking
themselves first so the step the
step-by-step process for that is
incredibly difficult because first they
have to separate themselves from this
thing that they love and usually that
happens naturally it doesn't happen
consciously it becomes oh I don't really
I'm 28 now I don't like kpop as much so
then they separate from that thing and
now they're just lost but you first have
to separate yourself from that thing and
now you're kind of lost in the ether now
you have to go back to well maybe I need
to stop hating myself then too I feel
okay with myself then too I love myself
and so there's a lot of steps in bed
Queen to get to that point and that's
incredibly difficult for people to do
nonetheless even recognize that they're
doing [ __ ] recognization I get it
together I know it's a very difficult
process but like I just need I just want
not need I want people to at least
acknowledge it acknowledge you know what
I feel like you know the key and peele
skit where there's a Obama's anger
translator yes I feel like I'm you're
calm trail because I used to be like
that case I wonder like this is gonna
sound really whack it may not be true
but also it's not out there I wonder if
we're also kind of mad at them because
we see ourselves and all of us examine
we're like I got to that you need to get
through that [ __ ] to IO but to an extent
David it's because you care oh for sure
I always say this to the qualities that
we hate in somebody else's the quality
that we see in ourselves yep I agree
yeah a hundred percent yes really what
it is so when I see that like for
example like it goes as far as this
where you guys take personal experiences
and you think there's somebody's
[ __ ] on your personal experience
like for example like like you know
Nicky loves Eminem right yeah I'm not
using this never this never happened but
I'm using this as an example like a fake
example I say Nicky loves Eminem right
yeah go like I don't think Eminem's that
dope of a rapper and then her response
to be like he helped me prevent myself
from killing myself he helped me through
my dark times I don't give a [ __ ] yeah I
don't cast your personal experience
right I'm just telling you that it did
it I don't like it
yeah what's the problem nobody's
[ __ ] a nobody [ __ ] on you that
kpop Eminem [ __ ] Tupac whatever
helped you in a dark place that's your
personal experience yeah but not
everybody has to share that experience
and not everybody yes yeah yeah okay
yeah that's what I'm trying to say right
if you guys want me to sing Cree music
se Cree music all day [ __ ] hey
oh don't put me on the spot [ __ ] oh man
that was a joke
tell us a joke you know how people do
that with standard creators they're like
say it do some funny funny man [ __ ]
sing a song David you're a comic oh can
you tell me a joke make me laugh okay
you
were born oh that's a joke excuse me
[ __ ] you gonna have you having such an
allergy attack right now my nose is so
itchy
my nose is really bad isn't it I don't
think so I can't tell Vicki yeah you
look fine thank you David and the posts
were far enough where I make sure that
people oh I don't even got that zoom in
[ __ ] oh my god and the reason why we had
the camera like this is I think people
really these blue or no you're the big
top down the side of her head
yeah I make sure it looks like people
are in the conversation that they're
just sitting right there hello camera
that's what it is
hello that's some see this is how people
should speak to each other
it's like agree and disagree yeah I like
this oh yeah because it's [ __ ] you David
well guys this wraps this episode of the
genius brain podcast wait
well guys this wraps this episode make
sure you follow me on instagram because
it's my only social platform big
crossbows and then make sure you follow
my guests my special guest today David
where can they find you or the genius
brain good y'all but check next year
Bose is gonna be working on some [ __ ] hi
open cousin till then I'm taking all her
[ __ ] on my podcast yeah dude everything
I got a deal when we do another episode
I might tell you what I do for work
nobody knows I spill all my tea on
David's podcast I'm [ __ ] love it but
catch us on iTunes if you see us on
iTunes give that five star or write
comments below converse I want to hear
your thoughts about everything see you
on the next episode [ __ ] love
yourself suck your own clip suck you
suck your own dick yes I can't it's too
small anyways guys see you next time
BAE